the 56th ordinary summit of echoes was
anything but ordinary these are
particularly difficult times for the
region as attacks by armed groups have
escalated in recent months the rising
violence in the Sahel and other parts of
West Africa dominated the speeches
Nigeria's president whose country has
had to deal with the threat from Boko
Haram for the past 10 years says closer
cooperation is needed along with more
international support terrorism remains
the major threat to the peace and
progress of our region recurrent attacks
by terrorist groups reminder of the
urgency to build an enduring security
partnership to confront and defeat the
evil of cross-border terrorism echo as
chairman and the just president whose
country recently lost 71 soldiers in an
attack by an ISIL affiliated group is in
no doubt about the effects of the
violence on member nations not reserved
a dorama a proven strategy our region
has been hit hard by terrorist attacks
which have intensified with every
passing day threatening the many
national and regional achievements we
have made the terrorist attacks
continually test our resolve to fighting
this scourge the leaders in the last
meeting in September agreed to set up a
1 billion dollar fund to pay for armies
to fight the armed groups 100 million
dollars of that is distributed but with
many countries in the region having to
fight their individual battles alone it
is feared that more than a billion
dollars will be needed to achieve peace
Mohammed evening chambers is the United
Nations Special Representative in West
Africa there's no question that the
moral post responses required because
what we are seeing is that the terrorist
groups are showing a lot of resistance
and with resilience and capacities which
we had underestimated and additionally
there has to be a response to address
the
forces of violent extremism
the meeting also reviewed guinea-bissau
s presidential elections and importantly
the plan for single currency next year
echo says seven countries now meet the
criteria for a single currency but it's
not clear if french-speaking countries
using the West African financial
community franc the CFA will digit and
when economies like Nigeria and Ghana
would want to adopt the plant common
currency the echo which is scheduled to
roll out in 2020 Hamid agrees al Jazeera
Abuja